- [Lauren] I'm Lauren from Khan Academy,
and today I'm going to
give you an overview
of how to set up accounts for yourself
and your children on Khan Academy.
We'll also go over how you
can find relevant content
for your kids and view their progress.
This video is meant for parents
with kids who are 12 or under.
If you child is 13 or older,
please see our other video
called Parent Quick Start Tips
for Kids Ages 13 Plus.
We will start by having
your child create an account
on Khan Academy.
Creating an account
lets you and your child
track progress and time spent learning.
Go to www.khanacademy.org
and click Sign up
in the upper right-hand corner.
On the sign up page, enter
your child's date of birth,
and click Sign up by choosing a username.
On the next page, enter
your email address,
and choose a username for your child.
Then click Sign up.
Next, choose a starting point
for your child's learning journey.
In the Personalize Khan Academy pop-up,
select your child's
grade and click continue.
On the next page, you'll see courses
that we recommend for your child.
Choose one or more and click continue.
You can also click the See all link
to view the full menu.
Your child is ready to go.
Have them click the blue
Start button for any course
to start with the very first lesson,
or click See all to
browse the entire course.
If you're not sure what
level your child is at,
here's a tip:
Most Khan Academy math courses
include a course challenge
that can help you quickly find where
your child needs practice
and where they're already
good to go.
To get there, scroll to the
bottom of the course page
and click Start Course challenge.
These usually take 30 to 45 minutes
and will give you some good clues
about where to direct their learning.
You can have you child
start one grade level
below their current grade or
even start at kindergarten
and work their way up.
Next, let's create a parent account.
You must create a parent
account within seven days,
or all child accounts will be deleted.
To create an account, check your email.
For each child, you'll have
an Approve your child's
Khan Academy account email waiting.
Click the green Allow my child
to use Khan Academy button.
Check your updates or other mail folders
if you don't see this email right away.
Follow the prompts to
sign up for a new account
or sign into an existing account,
using the email address
where you received the email.
Once you sign up, you'll be taken
to your parent dashboard.
If you want to view your child's progress,
you could click on your child's username.
This takes you to the progress report,
where you can keep track
of what they're learning
and how much time they're spending.
Your child can also see this report
through their account by clicking Progress
in their left navigation.
Thanks for watching, and we hope you
and your child enjoy
learning on Khan Academy.